there are six hundred forty trading
cards in total depicting stadium's
national flags and the players of the
2014 World Cup Jorah camilo has them all
the Portuguese football fan has been
buying and swapping all year now he's
got serious work to do it's unbelievable
it's really like something that you have
to to feel I prefer to have attempted
and to try to get all the stickers but
when I start for me it's terrible to to
be stopped so I have to start into to
finish the album the excitement will
only be over when he fills in all 80
pages Chihuahua has lived in the
Portuguese capital for 20 years he works
with his father in a hotel but his real
passion is football he writes for a
football magazine and every four years
he goes hunting for stickers and he's
not alone they're swapping going on all
over Lisbon and there's one player
people want in particular Portuguese
mega star Cristiano Ronaldo
and proud owners know where to look for
their treasure the kiosks are an
important meeting place for swappers as
personal kwanten way machine we sell
stickers all year long but we only get
these panini world cut stickers every
four years and there's a lot of demand
what's different is that these panini
stickers are collected mainly by adults
not only young people no son loves [ __ ]
soluta semi thousand única razón through
this closet the stickers are made in
Modena Italy that's where panini is
headquartered the panini brothers
founded the company in 1961 and brought
out their first sticker album in the
same year they released their first
world cup stickers and albums in 1970
when the World Cup took place in Mexico
now the stickers are available in more
than 110 countries there's speculation
about whether panini makes the same
number of each sticker but this doesn't
matter to the collectors chihuahua
Camino has all the World Cup albums
together they're worth several thousand
euros my question for stickers they
started since I remember myself I was
five years old I remember to say to my
mom please go to the library and buy me
all the packets of seekers you can you
can find he stuck in all the cards for
the 1978 world cup in Argentina himself
but he bought the album with the
nineteen seventy four championships in
Munich he's been offered between 300 and
600 euros for it but he's not selling
any of his albums
and he's not interested in going online
to buy or swap stickers either I need to
feel the the material and see the face
of the press the person which I'm
changing the stickers I've never changed
online but I know the young people do it
and i think it's it's positive but i
prefer a chalk and two know each other
even if we know each other only for two
or three minutes while some collectors
continue with their everyday routine Joe
is constantly on the move because he
doesn't want to miss any of the matches
he wants to be finished sticking before
the quarter finals begin the four-week
World Cup competition is tough work it
means a lot of games to two what big
bash and suffering enjoying and also
putting the results in panini album
after the after the games and control
everything yes it's it's a fluidity
fever and though there might be a little
less fever now that Portugal is out
there's still a lot of interest in the
final outcome this year my teeth for
Brazil 2014 is Argentina on the ball as
ever
you